really nice that they started to start
him he's coming off the bench
most of the year putting up incredible
numbers James Harden 3-point take a
timeout on the court rockets up 12 to 9
+ J no Bill's been around a long time
doing superior work great pass to capela
here's the alley-oop to capela watch
Capella's right elbow on the backboard
right there nice pass again he said hey
back away and then ii ducky you see
they're doubling james
capela is rolling down harden will bring
it up you don't come out and get him
that's what happened James Harden with
his second three again because he shoots
it so well and a terrific career at
Oklahoma
inside there's a the third assist of the
game for James Harden right hope you're
not gonna go in there and stop him it's
any easy way to score Austin Rivers
trying to stay with Barnes in the paint
Bartlett puts it up Bagley lost control
yeah they're really young really
talented out foxes 21 he'll is a veteran
he played
[Applause]
another basket by the bay PJ comes over
now to set of pics back out to danuel
house no-look pass by Hardy house who
you know that's the sense of urgency you
got to have you know the attacks rumors
all you got the age and they find a
guarded Bogdanovich Hardin just kind of
an afterthought just threw it up danuel
house extra pass to harden who's wide
open
if you said Cory is trying to act it out
the referee spell for Buddy hield
to the middle short and Harden with the
rebound
let's go dude here today harden steps
back again he's got 27 already in this
half box for the miss cappella years
today see the Kings getting so jumbled
no not quite yeah with the shot clock
inside the 14 pardons of the basket for
two
you see how quickly box picks up parts
bounce back at Eric Gordon Eric's got a
lot of room
[Music]
[Applause]
these kind of shooter is this kind of
room and that's just more opportunities
for them better get back where the Kings
never stop the boat I'm not going to
argue there are now working on Fox back
to CP 3 to the basket for to the
improvement I think 204 Clank a puppy he
extend his range out to the three-point
line over the next couple of years for
Susan I bet he can and Hardison flips it
up with the right
go back for something in the football
games works you can always count on him
to be where he needs to be Barbie step
back in family he had missed five threes
in a row
makes one James love that you'll wake
him up it is right there
come & get it good morning in terms of
wreath row shoes to the basket with a
floater
what are you gonna do they have
on the rare chance to build for the
future they can keep them all there
there's harden again floating it up an
end he's so soft around that room when
318 left to play Hardin with the
basketball five on the shot clock heart
lifted on James Harden
mm three quarters in his
that he heals around heart fires it up
and missed it badly trying to get it in
is it up and misted back late trying to
get it and harden got Arriba
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
rebound in science cappella
cherry-picking on the other end for an
easy one that's a devastating play there
for the Kings where they don't get to on
one end and they give up an easy two on
the other